[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 fit le journal ravi de vous
retrouver voici les titres de ce jeudi 8
janvier 2017
ils seront cinq candidats nouvelle donne
dans les yvelines créé en 2013 par
l'économiste pierre larrouturou ce
mouvement politique veut se faire une
place dans la recomposition de la gauche
benoît hamon était en meeting à trappes
dans son fief une campagne législative
difficile après les résultats de la
présidentielle pour le député sortant de
la 11e circonscription
le champion du monde de pétanque
malgache nanou et son compatriote cobras
ont participé au traditionnel tournoi du
club local de l'ue smc une compétition
organisée au parc jean carillo et on
ouvre ce journal avec les élections
législatives et le mouvement nouvelle
donne ils seront cinq candidats apporter
leurs idées dont les circonscription des
yvelines créé en 2013 par l'économiste
pierre larrouturou ce mouvement
politique veut se faire une place dans
la recomposition de la rose de la gauche
pardon
reportage de nicolas landry nouvelle
donne une référence au new deal cette
politique menée par le président
américain franklin roosevelt face à la
crise de 1929 et pour les représentants
yvelinois de ce mouvement
la priorité comme dans les années 30
c'est la lutte contre le chômage
la proposition forte de nouvelles donnes
les livres de pierre larrouturou
c'est sur le partage du travail avec des
solutions pragmatiques expliqué validé
par des économistes deuxième point sera
basé sur l'écologie
cinq candidats soutiendront ses
propositions dans les yvelines comme
gilles pons le voit dans la 2e
circonscription michel lavezzari dans la
3e ou encore marie thérèse manteau ni
dans la dixième fonctionnaires de
l'éducation nationale cette dernière a
adhéré au mouvement en 2014
elle se présente avec une idée de son
rôle de député considère que la mission
de député c'est voter des lois au niveau
du national mais c'est aussi être
présents dans une circonscription et
être vraiment à l'écouté des personnes
pour justement faire remonter
et vraiment être sur le terrain pour ce
que de toute façon on peut pas faire les
choses à distance comme ça voilà il faut
vraiment entendre ce que ce que les gens
à fond à dire pour pouvoir penser après
et faire des propositions concrètes qui
tienne la route lors de la
présidentielle nouvelle donne a appelé
sur un ton humoristique à une
candidature benoît hameçons pour ce
scrutin législatif sur le territoire
yvelinois il n'y aura pas de candidature
pour le mouvement dans plusieurs
circonscriptions la 11e circonscription
on va laisser benoît hamon défendre ses
idées par exemple c'est clair benoît
hamon dans sa candidature à la
présidentielle à exprimer des idées très
proches des nôtres donc on va pas lui
faire un croche pied
je retrouve
plus de 80% des idées de nouvelles
donnes je peux me sentir proche du
programme de france insoumise
après du fonctionnement du mode de
discours de la façon d'être de france
info me gêne un peu plus de mal face à
la situation du parti socialiste et à la
modification du système partisan
le mouvement de pierre larrouturou veut
participer à la recomposition politique
pour engendrer une nouvelle donne dans
l'histoire de la gauche française
une campagne discrète vis-à-vis des
médias
benoît hamon était en meeting mardi
dernier à trappes la commune dont il
était conseiller municipal jusqu'en
janvier 2016 l'ancien candidat
socialiste à l'élection présidentielle
et le député sortant de la 11e
circonscription meloni poquet et patrick
jacq de bix mute l'ont rencontré accueil
chaleureux pour les candidats
socialistes surtout des plus jeunes pour
ce meeting le candidat et député sortant
de la 11e circonscription et attrapes
dans son fief
je pense que dans cette circonscription
j'ai besoin aussi de retrouver
l'honnêteté d'une relation avec des
habitants qui se passe de
l'intermédiaire des médias autant une
campagne présidentielle les médiations
important autant d'initiatives j'avais
très envie de quelque chose d'un peu
plus brut
une campagne législative difficile après
celle de la présidentielle cinquième au
niveau national avec 6% des voix
benoît hamon fait un peu mieux dans sa
circonscription mais loin des manuels
macro et jean luc mélenchon au premier
tour il est arrivé quatrième avec 12%
moi je veux bâtir cette nouvelle société
avec d'autres et ça commence par les
élections législatives on voit bien
qu'il va y avoir un démantèlement
méthodique du code du travail et des
protections des salariés
moi je me refuse absolument et mais pas
simplement pour dire non à ce que fait
macro mais aussi pour dire quelles
alternatives on lui propose et
l'alternative c'est la reconnaissance
par exemple du grenoble comme maladie
professionnelle l'alternative c'est
privilégier la réduction du temps de
travail une meilleure articulation entre
le travail que l'on a et sa vie
personnelle plutôt que demain contre un
travail ou votre employeur décide des
conditions dans lesquelles vous serez
licenciés dans la salle des fidèles de
la première heure des élus de la commune
et des proches et va changer beaucoup de
choses
échanges il a des idées pour nos jeux
parce qu'il ya des jeunes qui n'ont pas
de travail taille à cela il faut leur cv
et des causses et les cévennes habitat
pas c'est fini il faut mettre toutes les
chances de notre côté toutes les chances
de leur côté pour garder benoît comme
député on en a besoin nous sur trappe et
sur la circonscription mais je pense
qu'on a besoin aussi sur le plan
national d'avoir un député de la sorte
qu'ils puissent faire entendre en tout
cas porter la parole de ceux qui ont
voté pour lui
pour ce premier tour 12 autres candidats
se présentent benoît hamon affrontera
notamment le 11 juin prochain
jean michel fourgous député de la
circonscription de 2002 à 2012 et nadia
et candidates la république en marche
francis lalanne à la gare de saint rémy
les chevreuse hier soir le chanteur
co-président du mouvement 100% et de
l'alliance écologiste indépendante est
venu parler de son combat pour une
écologie
au centre de tout quelques tracts
distribués à des voyageurs pressés et
pas de candidats du département présents
avec lui et cela n'a pas découragé a
présenté sa vision de la société la
protection la défense de la nature et le
respect du vivant et d engagement
citoyen dont la 12e' à tirer on a par
exemple dans nos programmes est ce qu'on
appelle les systèmes d'échangés locaux
les selles ou justement vous avez un
appareil photo qui vous sert plus aux en
voulait plus quelqu'un d'autre un
aspirateur dont vous avez besoin bail
il faut qu'ils soient informés que vous
ayez un que les lui il a besoin d'un
appareil photo une fiction a informé que
que vous avez cet appareil vous allez
changer
on a aussi par le mit en place talent la
banque du temps donc du temps c'est beau
boubou par exemple dans la journée vous
avez du temps vous pourriez consacré aux
autres il faut que les autres le sachent
qu'ils puissent vous sollicitez dans la
12e circonscription des yvelines c'est
la candidate françoise pinson qui
représente le parti communiste français
un mouvement qu'elle a rejoint il ya
plus de vingt ans elle était suppliant
dans la sixième circonscription des
yvelines pour les législatives de 2012
cette fois elle se présente comme
candidate dans la 12e et développe ses
axes de campagne au micro de camille
lambert c'est surtout contre la loi
travail et contrôler les ordonnances là
c'est les axes aussi parce que plus on
aura de députés au niveau 2
de ses instances et de l'assemblée plus
on pourra et faire reculer le ces lois
qui sont complètement à l inverse de ce
que pour laquelle on se bat je suis pas
du tout une professionnelle de la
politique et mon but il
il n'est pas de faire sa bombe utile et
des proches des gens et d'apporter les
valeurs que le parti il a par rapport à
aux gens par rapport aux piquets et
pisciacaise une campagne des
législatives qui bat son plein à trois
jours du premier tour ce matin valérie
pécresse est venue soutenir françois
xavier bellamy candidats aux élections
législatives dans la première
circonscription à la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines la présidente de la
région ile de france a reconnu les
qualités d'élu de terrain du candidat
c'est vrai qu'être député s'est portée
des valeurs et un projet à l'assemblée
nationale mais c'est aussi défendre un
territoire et porter la voix des
habitants de ce territoire
et de ce point de vue être élu local
connaître le territoire y être engagée
depuis des années c'est important et
c'est pour ça que françois xavier a
souhaité que je vienne ici à la gare de
montigny parce qu'un énorme enjeu sur
les transports quand on habite les
yvelines un énorme enjeu de
modernisation un énorme enjeu de
sécurisation et de confort dans la
première circonscription des yvelines
florence imbert fait partie des 14
candidats qui se présentent pour obtenir
un siège à l'assemblée nationale
cet enseignant de 50 ans qui habite à
versailles sera la représentante du
mouvement demain en commun une femme
politique qui nous présente ces trois
axes de campagne au micro de michael et
me d'euros je pense qu'il y a un aspect
très important de mon programme qui est
les droits des femmes
je pense qu'il est indispensable qu'il y
ait une parité absolue dans tous les
domaines politique et économique
deuxième axe les
l'écologie est là l'appropriation par
les habitants de leur patrimoine naturel
donc la création l'entretien des espaces
verts que gérer et partager le troisième
axe est un axe sociétale alors je pense
qu'il est très important que les
français les les françaises et les
français se réapproprient la vie
politique et se met à participer
activement à des projets citoyens
près de 47 millions d'électeurs sont
appelés aux urnes pour élire leurs 577
députés les dimanches 11 et 12 18 pardon
11 et 18 juin prochains des
parlementaires qui siègeront à
l'assemblée nationale pendant un mandat
de cinq ans mais quel est le rôle de ces
élus nationaux pourront parler nicolas
landry nicolas bonsoir de son stephen
quelles sont les fonctions d'un député
alors le député s'inscrit dans le
pouvoir législatif sa première fonction
est de proposer fabriquer et voter les
lois
un travail réalisé en commission comme
vous voyez à l'image huit au total
classés en fonction des domaines traités
par la loi on retrouve par exemple les
affaires économiques les affaires
sociales ou encore les affaires
étrangères ce travail permet de préparer
les débats en séance publique dans
l'hémicycle
c'est aussi à ce moment là que le député
exerce son droit d'amendement un droit
qui permet de proposer des modifications
dans le texte de loi examiné et c'est
seulement après ce travail en commission
que le député vote un texte
quelles relations entretiennent les
députés avec le gouvernement c'est très
clair stéphane le député contrôler
l'action gouvernementale
chaque semaine ils interpellent les
ministres lors de la séance des
questions au gouvernement
des questions concernant des enjeux
nationaux ou des problématiques dans sa
circonscription le dépô t le député
pardon a aussi le pouvoir d' évaluer les
politiques publiques à travers des
rapports d expertise menée grâce à des
auditions de hauts fonctionnaires ou de
personnalités de la société civile
vous l'avez compris pour mener ses
réformes le président de la république a
besoin d'une majorité au parlement une
majorité qui permet de nommer un premier
ministre de sa famille politique
le chef du gouvernement doit obtenir la
confiance de l'assemblée nationale lors
d'un vote
après son discours de politique générale
qui intervient après sa nomination
en revanche si la majorité des députés
sont opposés au président de la
république nous nous retrouvons dans une
cohabitation une situation intervenus
fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république en 1986 1993 et en 1997
merci nicolas dans l'agenda maintenant
des réunions politiques dans la 2e
circonscription jean noël barrot de la
république en marche sera ce soir à
20h30 à l'école pierre corneille à
versailles dans la 2e circonscription
jean guy sayus divers-droite démocratie
citoyenne sera ce soir à 21h à la salle
des sports de beauplan à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse dans la
troisième circonscription nicolas tardy
joubert dvd sera ce soir à 20h30 à
l'école henri prou aux clayes sous bois
et enfin dans la 10e circonscription
david jutier écologiste sera à 20h30 à
la salle municipale des essarts le roi
une opération solidaire au carrefour
market de voisins-le-bretonneux
l'association anaïs du rêve à l'espoir
étaient présentes pour récolter des dons
au profit d'une jeune fille handicapée
les soins qu'elle doit suivre ne sont
pas remboursés et l'association compte
sur la générosité des visiteurs pour
améliorer son quotidien
l'objectif était là de récolter
suffisamment pour pouvoir aménager la
maison en fonction de ses besoins
on écoute la présidente de l'association
au micro de camille lambert
l'association a été créée il y a trois
ans pour aider anaïs une
petite fille handicapée moteur qui a eu
un accident la naissance c'est pour lui
permettre de financer des thérapies de
rééducation que l'on fait principalement
à l'étranger est également de financer
du matériel médical qui est très peu
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
et aujourd'hui on a un autre besoin
c'est de financer l'aménagement de la
maison une salle de bain adaptée
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivis tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver sur tv fil 78 points
comme et sur l'application tv fil 78
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]